Speaker 1: We're right in the middle of a very
interesting and globally significant story
whose details are changing so quickly that by the
time today's episode goes live, you may actually
know more than I know right now. And it has to
do with Nancy Pelosi, the Speaker of the House
in the United States, the country of China and
Taiwan, and understanding some of the history of
the United States, China and Taiwan is important
to understanding what's going on, which we will,
of course, get to to begin with. The big story is
Nancy Pelosi is was at least as of this morning,
expected to visit Taiwan, according to Taiwanese
and United States officials. And as CNN says,
Nancy Pelosi is on a tour of Asia. And despite
warnings from Biden administration officials
and from China, Nancy Pelosi is
believed to be heading to Taiwan.
This is certainly controversial when it comes to
China because of the policy of the United States
of at least for foreign relations and geopolitical
negotiation purposes. Recognizing China and China
alone, although the U.S. has supported Taiwanese
membership in a number of different coalitions
and organizations over the years, sort of staking
out not what I would call a 5050 position on China
and Taiwan, but certainly not a policy that is as
extreme and reactionary as what China would want,
which is to pretend that there is no such thing,
even as Taiwan sort of out in the world. This
would be, as the CNN article says, the first stop
in Taiwan for a U.S. House speaker in 25 years.
It is not currently on Pelosi's public itinerary.
And this is being interpreted one of two ways.
One way in which this is being interpreted is
they've decided to bail on the Taiwan visit.
The counterpoint is, well, it just was never
on the itinerary. So it's a signal that she may
still plan to do it, but it's at least not being
given the same sort of position and significance
that other visits are being given by virtue of
not being placed on the official itinerary. The
Taiwanese official added that Pelosi is expected
to stay in Taiwan overnight. It's unclear when
she would be in Taipei. The U.S. official added
that Defense Department officials are working
around the clock on monitoring Chinese movements
and securing a plan to keep Nancy Pelosi safe.
China has issued warnings saying the military will
not stand idly by. If Nancy Pelosi visits Taiwan
now. The least. I don't know if charitable
is the right word to use here, but the least
charitable or most aggressive interpretation of
this comment would be that the Chinese military
would target Nancy Pelosi specifically. That does
not seem to be the consensus opinion right now.
But there's a lot of questions around what's
going on. This is a Reuters report which says
the latest warning was issued
during a Chinese foreign ministry
regular briefing. Spokesperson Zhao Lijian
also said that because of Pelosi's status as
the number three official of the U.S. government,
a visit to Taiwan, which China claims as its own,
would, quote, lead to egregious political impact.
Pelosi was set to kick off a tour of four Asian
countries Monday in Singapore, with speculation
that she risks the wrath of Beijing by visiting
Self-Ruled Taiwan. This is a very interesting
geopolitical story and also potentially
of significant consequence because US-China
relations are not particularly strong right now.
Donald Trump, by virtue of his what do we even
call it, belligerent posturing about Taiwan,
about China, rather, has arguably sunk those
relations to a new low. A year of talking
about the China virus certainly didn't help. And
although things have not further escalated under
Joe Biden, they certainly haven't been repaired in
any significant way. The official position of the
United States when it comes to China policy is
not overtly supporting Taiwanese independence,
but supporting Taiwanese membership in some
international organizations. That includes the
WTO. The U.S. says, okay, we don't recognize
Taiwan's independence, but we recognize that
Taiwan as an entity should be part of the World
Trade Organization. Well, usually it's countries
that are members of that, so it creates this kind
of arguably deliberately nebulous situation. The
U.S. has supported Taiwanese membership in the
Asia-Pacific Pacific Economic Cooperation Forum,
the Asian Development Bank. Now, you
don't need to be an independent state
to be a member of the Asian Development Bank.
So it's a, generally speaking, pro-China policy
that is not pro-China enough for China. And we
will see what happens here. We will see what Nancy
Pelosi ultimately does. And probably in the next
24 to 48 hours, we will have more news about it.